اهلا بكم اذا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري وسيكون معنا على
الخارطه التفاعليه الزميل محمود الكن ولكن
قبل الذهاب الى محمود نشير الى انه منذ
بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه في
السابع من اكتوبر تعرضت المصالح والقواعد
الامريكيه في المنطقه الى العديد من
الهجمات هي هجمات تقول الجهات المسؤوله عن
ها انها جاءت ردا على الحرب الاسرائيليه
على غزه وقد جاء هجوم اليوم ليشكل منعطفا
مع مقتل واصابه جنود امريكيين في استهداف
قوات امريكيه في الاردن وذلك وفقا للقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه الان محمود سيطلع لنا
اكثر على تفاصيل هذا الهجوم تفضل نعم ليلى
دعينا نبدا من الاحداث الاقليميه كما
ذكرتي هنا الخريطه نشاهد فيها ا الحدود
مثلث الحدود الاردن العراق وسوريا هذا هو
البرج 22 او ايضا هو في ضمن منطقه الركبان
على الحدود وهنا قاعده التنف اذا ما
اقتربنا اكثر الى هذه المنطقه سنشاهد
الشكل الجغرافي هنا هنا الحدود العراقيه
لكن البرج 22 يبعد حوالي كر و200 متر او
اقل حتى من كيلومتر اذا كان من حدود
القاعده العسكريه موجوده هنا البرج 22 في
حين تبعد ا التنف حوالي 20 كيلومترا عن
الحدود كما نشاهد حسب الخط الذي نراه في
هذه المنطقه اذا هذا التصعيد طبعا تقول
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه تم ضمن
منطقه البرج 22 في حين تقول تنفي ذلك
الاردن وتقول انه كان ضمن قاعده التنف
وليس ضمن
الحدود الاردنيه اذا هذا التصعيد ما زلنا
ب انتظار المزيد من المعلومات عنه كيف
عملت ما هو نوع المسيرات وكيف يمكن
لمضادات
الجويه مضادات المسيرات
اي الت تكون فشلت في صد هذا الهجوم لكن
القوات المهاجمه ذكرت ان ذلك لا ينفصل عن
غزه كما ذكرنا في الاخبار ما الذي يحدث
الان في قطاع دعونا نشاهد ما الذي يحدث
هناك هذه
الخارطه نشاهد فيها المناورات الاسرائيليه
وحركه وحركه الاليات باللون الاصفر تغيرت
بشكلين رئيسيين هنا في الشمال بيت لاهيه
بيت حانون كان هناك ازيل اللون الاصفر
خلال الايام الماضيه وذلك لان الاليات
الاسرائيليه لم تعد موجوده لكن ذلك ترافق
مع قصف مدفعي وطيران في هذه المنطقه ما قد
يعزز هذه المعلومه بسبب ان الطيران او
المدفعيه تقوم بالقصف عاده دون وجود الق
قوات
ال دون وجود القوات البريه الان اذا ما
اتجهنا الى المنطقه الوسطى ايضا هناك
تغيير رئيسي هذه المنطقه هنا في
الوسط سنشاهد بان اللون الاصفر اختفى على
محور صلاح الدين في المنطقه الممتده هنا
بين النصيرات والبريج والمغازي هذه هي
المنطقه التي اتحدث عنها الاليات
الاسرائيليه لم تعد موجود منذ نحو خمسه
ايام لكنها ما تزال تتحرك في هذا النطاق
اخيرا نتجه الى خان
يونس مركز ثقل العمليات هنا في الغرب
والجنوب حيث كانت اعلنت قوات او فصائل
المقاومه بانها تصدت لدبابات ميركافا في
هذين المحورين وانسحبت هنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال بانه سحب لوائين هو اللواء
55 هذا مظلي اضافه الى الى لواء كرياتي
بالتالي هناك خمس الويه عامله الان في
جنوب قطاع غزه هذا ابرز ما لدينا ليلى
شكرا سننطلق من هذه النقاط التي اشرت
اليها للتو لواء فايز النمط القتالي
وتوزيع القتال في مناطق القطاع كيف يمكن
وصفها اليوم الان يعني الخارطه اللي عرضها
محمود اذا سمح يعرض لنا اياها المنطقه
الشماليه هذه هناك قرار بانسحاب القوات
والدخول لتنفيذ مهمات فقط لا غير الان هذا
اللون الاصفر هي مناطق حركه القوات عندما
تدخل تدخل من الشمال وتنسحب من الشرق
وتنسحب لكن النقطه الاساسيه في هذا الشيء
هو الشريط ال الذي ياتي من اقصى زاويه
الشمال الشرقي مرورا مع السياج حتى اقصى
اليمين هذه مسافه 650 الى 1000 متر التي
تهدف الى انشاء
منطقه عازله وتدمر تدميرا ممنهجا لكافه
المباني الموجوده في هذه المنطقه اذا لا
معارك حاسمه في الشمال فقط عمليات تدخل
المعارك الحاسمه حدثت في منطقتين في منطقه
التفاح وجباليا والدروج وجباليا ومخيم
جباليه وانكفى وانسحبت منطقه الوسط فشلت
القوات ا تعطينا خارطه الوسط لو سمحت فشلت
القوات في يعني هي نجحت جزئيا في في فصل
المخيمات الاربع عن بعضها لكنها بعد تلقي
الضربه الاخيره في شرق المغازي المصدر
وهذا راح راح فيها اكثر من
21 جندي من جيش الاحتلال وفشلها في تحقيق
اي انجاز في منطقه البريج انكف هذه القوات
وابقت على المنطقه العازله بين البريج
والمغازي لاحظ سيرات الزوايده كان يوجد
قوات ولكنها تراجعت الى المنطقه الشرقيه
وهذه المنطقه منطقه يوجد فيها ثلاثه الويه
ثلاثه الويه مظليين كوماندز ولء دروع
المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي المنطقه الاساسيه
الان من حيث الصراع ودائره الصراع كذلك
اذا نظرنا الى الخارطه نجد انه منطقه
القراره ومدينه الحمد والرشيد تحدثنا
كثيرا عن هذه الاحاطه الان ما يظهر في عند
كلمه الزنه ه ها المنطقه الصفراء هذه اللي
هو جاءت قبل ثلاث ايام هجوم من الش
لتعزيز النجاح من الهجوم القادم من منطقه
المواصي كذلك تحدثنا ل عده مرات عن التقرب
الذي تم من منطقه الفخاري الى قيزان
النجار وعامله تماس معع السؤال الان لماذا
سحب
لوائين لماذا نعم لانه هذا يث يثير الفضول
اقول الان التركيز رغم يعني السحب
اللواءين ياتي في وقت تصر في اسرائيل انها
تحرز تقدم نعم يعني قد يبدو الامر متعارض
لكني لا م وجهه نظر عسكريه جد
منطقي كيف منطقي الان نذهب الى المنطقه
الشرقيه المنطقه الشرقيه اذا قارناها
مساحه مع مدينه خان يونس اضعاف اضعاف يوجد
فيها من قوات النخبه من مختلف الفصائل
تحديدا من القسام وسرايا القدس يعني على
مستوى خزاعه لاسابيع واسابيع واسابيع
دمروا خزاع ولم يستطيعوا الدخول بها الان
عمليه الامتدادات من الشرق الى الطريق
صلاح الدين نجحت فقط في اقصى شمال عبسان
الجديده واقصى جنوب
عبسان الكبيره فبالتالي اصبحت هذه المنطقه
خسائر الجيش الاحتلال فيها عاليه طبيعه
الارض شبكه الانفاق المسافات البينيه فاثر
الان ان يذهب الى المنطقه الاكثر اهميه
موج وجهه نظري لانه يعتقد
ان الصف الاول من السياسيين والعسكريين في
في حماس القسام موجودين في هذه المنطقه
ويعتقد
ان معظم الرهائن موجودين في هذه المنطقه
منطقه خان يونس لهذا السبب شدد هجومه على
خان يونس وبالتالي هذه القوات التي كانت
في في المنطقه الشرقيه كانت متوغل اكثر ان
كفات اصبح لديه فائض قوه هذا الفائض او
هذا السحب قد يفسر في اكثر من بن اولا هذه
القوات لها اكثر من 100 يوم تقاتل هذه
القوات وقع فيها اصابات قد تكون اكثر من
60% لكن هناك وجهه نظر اخرى ممكن ان
يحركها نح الش نعم هناك وجهه نظر اخرى انه
المنطقه الحدوديه ما بين لبنان وشمال
فلسطين المحتله هناك تصريحات جازمه واضحه
بانه على حزب الله ان يلتزم بالقرار
1701 وعليه ان ينكف الى ما وراء الليطاني
اذا لم يسحب قواته حتى ولو او اوقف اطلاق
النار سنستمر في ذلك بالامس كان في تقارير
واضحه ان هناك عمليات تعزيز للبعد
اللوجستي الامداد من حيث الامداد لماذا
لانه عمليات التعزيز وتوفير المقدرات
اللوجستيه سواء كانت طبيه او وقود او غذاء
او حتى ذخيره يحتاج الى وقت اكثر من من
حركه القوه اذا هذا يفسر اذا سحب لوائين
قد يكون الان قد الان اعتبرت قوه فائضه عن
الحاجه وقد تبرزها الحاجه في اقصى الشمال
الشمال شكرا جزيلا لك فايز دويري